[Música]
la derecha gana los comicios en chile
para elegir a los miembros del Consejo
constitucional el servicio electoral ha
contado más del 95% de los sufragios y
los Ultra conservadores de José Antonio
kast fueron los más votados con casi el
36% ampliamos desde Santiago
27 personas murieron en Perú luego de
que se desencadenara un incendio en una
mina de oro es el accidente minero más
mortal que ha habido en el país en más
de dos décadas y los familiares de las
víctimas buscan información
y la provincia de Alberta en Canadá
entró en estado de emergencia por los
incendios forestales cerca de 30.000
personas han sido evacuadas Y
actualmente hay más de 100 fuegos
activos de los cuales por lo menos 30
están fuera de control
Bienvenidos a las noticias que France 24
dedica a América yo soy María Clara
calle
empezábamos en Chile porque hay
resultados sobre la elección de los 50
miembros del Consejo constitucional que
terminarán el segundo borrador de la
Carta Magna la derecha y la extrema
derecha ganaron la mayoría con más del
95% de los votos contados el partido
republicano del ultraconservador José
Antonio kast obtuvo casi el 36%, el
porcentaje supera el 50% si se suman los
de chile seguro que incluye el
movimiento de derecha del expresidente
Sebastián Piñera en contraste unidad
para Chile que respalda al actual
mandatario de izquierda Gabriel borich
tuvo poco menos del 30% en Santiago está
nuestra corresponsal Patricia Luna
Patricia bienvenida Y cuéntenos qué más
muestran los resultados del Consejo
constitucional
pues muestra muchas cosas y van a ser
muy analizados en los próximos días pero
sin duda son estos resultados son El
peor de los mundos para el oficialismo
que iba en dos listas separadas pero
esperaba reunir dos quintos de los
escaños para poder frenar las
iniciativas hemos dado un giro completo
a las ruedas en el proceso anterior la
izquierda por vía negociar las normas
sin contar con la derecha ahora a la
derecha si se alinea podrá negociar las
normas sin tener en cuenta en ningún
momento a la izquierda el presidente
Gabriel borics realizó un discurso hace
poco aceptando los resultados
evaluandolos y también pidiendo al
partido republicano que no cometan los
mismos errores que se cometieron que
cometieron ellos En el anterior proceso
y pongan el bien del país antes de
venganzas o temas personales el avance
del partido republicano es impresionante
con una campaña en la que se desplegó en
todo chile y que tuvo mucho de que ver
con los temas de contingencia
aunque aunque no están con un diseño
constitucional fueron muy efectivos en
el discurso de borich también se
mencionó temas cercanos a la ciudadanía
como los problemas de seguridad que
afronta el país los problemas de
migración o el tema de la inflación
entre otros son algunos de los aspectos
que han calado en esta elección que dará
mucho que hablar el tema también es si
los resultados se van a trasladar a una
oposición mucho más envejecida todavía
en el congreso Gracias Patricia por este
análisis ahora ante la victoria de la
derecha La pregunta es qué tantos
cambios tendrá realmente la nueva
constitución chilena respecto a la Carta
Magna de los tiempos de la dictadura
Esto fue lo que nos respondió Valentina
rosas magister en políticas públicas de
la Universidad de Oxford y miembro de la
red de politólogas de Chile
ese probablemente la mayor pregunta hoy
día el partido republicano no estuvo en
el acuerdo del Congreso Nacional en el
que se llegó a a esta decisión de
continuar el proceso Constituyente ellos
no fueron parte de ese acuerdo porque
estaban en contra de un proceso
constitucional que llevara a una nueva
constitución esto nos lleva a un
escenario donde quienes estaban en
contra hoy día están a cargo del proceso
constitucional eso obviamente es muy
complejo Y esa es la gran interrogante
si el partido republicano a final de año
va a apostar al rechazo de este texto y
quedar con la actual Constitución que es
con la que defienden o si van a tomar
este proceso como uno propio lo que
tendría que llevarlos un poco al centro
para poder no solo capitalizar este
activo que lo han hecho muy bien sino
generar un proyecto político que sepa
convocar a más del 50 por ciento de la
población en otras noticias el domingo
salió desde chile el vuelo humanitario
que envió el gobierno de Venezuela
115 venezolanos regresaron a su país de
origen después de estar más de dos
semanas varados en la frontera chileno
peruana Esta última nación Lima
concretamente rechazó a los migrantes
tras decretar estado de emergencia los
detalles con Luis Muñoz
de vuelta a casa este domingo más de un
centenar de venezolanos regresaron a su
país lo hicieron desde arica en el norte
de Chile en un vuelo humanitario
costeado por el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro en el conocido como plan vuelta a
la patria
Sí igual desde el día uno que uno sale
los migrantes llevaban días varados en
la frontera entre chile y Perú primero
habían tratado de llegar a tacna en Perú
para seguir a pie hacia su destino final
de Estados Unidos pero fueron rechazados
por las autoridades migratorias peruanas
y terminaron en arica Chile hasta esta
resolución final afortunadamente las
reglas y las leyes de chile se pusieron
un poco fuerte para nosotros para
conseguir trabajo Fue un poco complicado
sin embargo bueno tuvimos que tomar la
decisión de regresar el presidente de
Chile Gabriel borich celebro el
desenlace Este primer vuelo
de Ramos soluciones el gobierno chavista
por su parte se auto anotó un tanto a su
política exterior en un nuevo Triunfo de
la diplomacia bolivariana de paz el
gobierno venezolano trajo de vuelta a Su
patria 115 con nacionales que se
encontraban varados en la frontera de
chile desde 2018 Cuando entró en vigor
este plan de regreso 30.000 personas
desde 25 naciones han vuelto a Venezuela
y del otro lado de la frontera en Perú
hubo un incendio en una mina de oro el
gobierno local reporta 27 fallecidos y
la policía sostiene que el fuego fue
causado por un corto circuito en un
túnel la compañía
emitió un comunicado en el que
puntualizó que 175 trabajadores fueron
evacuados Y aunque agregó que los
fallecidos pertenecían a una empresa
contratista no reveló los nombres amable
nos amplía
familiares de Mineros esperan ansiosos
información en el exterior de la mina de
oro la esperanza en la región de
Arequipa al sur de Perú allí 27
trabajadores murieron en un incendio
en un total de
48 personas no a la unidad No estuve en
la noche en donde lamentablemente no
hemos perdido a 27 personas no una cifra
confirmada por el gobierno de Perú
expresamos nuestras condolencias a los
familiares y al pueblo de Arequipa por
la muerte de los 27 Mineros hecho
ocurrido en el sector de yanaquiwa
provincia de condesuyos en Arequipa un
cortocircuito habría causado la tragedia
imágenes difundidas en redes sociales
mostraron una gran columna de humo
proveniente de la mina mientras medios
locales indicaron que en el momento del
cortocircuito había personal trabajando
a unos 80 metros de profundidad el
sector minero es uno de los principales
pilares de la economía peruana ya que
representa el 8,3% del producto interno
bruto el país es el segundo productor
mundial de cobre plata y zinc y el
primer productor de oro de América
Latina este tipo de incidente no es
excepcional en este país en 2020 cuatro
mineros quedaron atrapados en el
derrumbe de una mina artesanal también
en la región de Arequipa los incendios
forestales en Canadá provocaron que la
provincia de Alberta entrara en estado
de emergencia cerca de 30.000 personas
han sido evacuadas y las causas podrían
ser las inusuales altas temperaturas
veamos
filas interminables de conductores
desesperados por llegar a un lugar
seguro miles de residentes del suroeste
del estado de Alberta buscan huir de las
llamas y acatar la orden de evacuación
emitida por las autoridades mientras un
feroz incendio se acerca a zonas
residenciales
fue aterrador
Solo espero que todo se hayan ido
estoy un poco ansioso por lo que pase Y
como estaba todo cuando volvamos
no sé si nuestra casa todavía estará
allí mañana no lo sé
en el Horizonte la manta de humo opaco
solo se hace más grande la provincia
occidental de Canadá ha estado en llamas
Durante los últimos días Los Fuertes
vientos hacen que los incendios
forestales continúen avanzando en el
suelo seco y boscoso incluso amenazando
las operaciones de extracción de
petróleo en la región las autoridades
locales han declarado el estado de
emergencia actualmente hay 103 incendios
forestales activos en Alberta que queman
121.909 hectáreas y desde ayer ha habido
35 nuevos incendios forestales a pesar
del despliegue de los cuerpos de Socorro
un tercio de los incendios siguen fuera
de control debido a las altas
temperaturas que se están presentando
durante esta temporada de primavera en
Alberta de 10 a 15 grados centígrados
por encima de lo normal
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con France
[Música]